yet with each fond remembrance we knew
those encountered were not forgotten
that someday we would see them again
perhaps it was no more than wishful
thinking
but after the long calm there are now
the beginnings of a stir the reunion at
hand may bring joy it may bring fear but
let us embrace whatever it brings for
they are coming back at last the promise
has been made
hey youtubers is charlie so hopefully in
between screaming and crying about the
game of thrones any you guys have seen
some of the stuff coming out at e3 this
is going to be like a shut up and take
my money breakdown with trailers for
those of you asking like which platform
I like to play on the most typically pc
is the easiest just because i have the
most control over how i capture and
stream footage but i do have an xbox one
and i have a ps4 on the way well because
of my list here i might have to buy a
wii u so let's get going so let's start
with the BR games so they're not a whole
lot going on with VR right now so I
wouldn't advise you to like rush out and
preorder one of the headsets Sony's is
called project Morpheus it's really
impressive like it's supposed to be the
most comfortable one and they did show
off a few games but you're locked into
Sony hardware you can't use it with your
pc games you can only use it with a ps4
welcome back little godly valves version
is called the vivre it's a little more
impressive it uses a couple different
controllers to map your environment so
you can actually like get up and walk
around inside the room where you're
playing games with it everybody knows
about oculus that's actually coming from
facebook of all places which makes it
sound a little bit evil its motion
tracking isn't quite as impressive as
valves vivre headset but it'll be
cheaper that's really the name of the
game here it's like what games will
these support will I be able to play it
with my pc games and my console games
oculus that's a yes you'll be able to
play it with your pc games and with your
xbox games for sure they announced a
partnership with Microsoft but Microsoft
is also making the hollow lens which is
not a VR headset it's a little bit
different it's more about Holograms
think of it as augmented reality like
you make a hologram shoot up in the
middle of your room but your room itself
isn't a VR environment you're seeing
your actual room all the headsets right
now are super glitchy they're not going
to be ready till next year so do not
blow any of your money on them I'm
planning on buying at least one of these
just depending on what the support for
games is it'll probably end up being the
valve eve I'm really excited to try and
make some videos with these but the
problem is is that if you don't have the
headset then you can't really take
advantage of a three DVR video it's a
very different experience so moving into
Sony they they actually had a couple
surprises they had one of the
better III presentations starting with
last guardian this is like the game that
wouldn't give up I remember years ago
when the ps3 first debuted and they were
like look at this beautiful game that
you will never ever see and hear it is
they rolled it out so thank you very
much Sony for that they had some pretty
good star wars battlefront gameplay
footage I'm excited for this game
battlefront games are fun so even if
this wasn't super great i would still
probably buy it because I'm a huge Star
Wars fan if someone were to ask you what
music makes you want to buy things the
most i would say John Williams Star Wars
theme don't be surprised if this
December like every retail store is just
playing the Star Wars theme on loop the
Final Fantasy 7 remake that's that's
just an auto by even if that was
terrible which is not I would still buy
it the other auto by should be kingdom
hearts 3 that was like the game
everyone's been waiting for that to me
is way more fun than Disney infinity
rise of the Tomb Raider also look
goddamn beautiful then there's the
really weird drakengard spin-off near to
I think that's just a temporary name so
it might end up changing it people are
calling it hyper violent so I guess if
you're looking for like a more adult RPG
then this will be the game for you
Dragon Quest Kingdom Hearts those will
be a lot lighter I'm also really excited
about Metal Gear Solid 5 and uncharted
there's the transformers devastation
game which uses a lot of cell shading
this looks like it might be fun it's a
little lower on my buy list but just
watching it gets me a little excited
moving into the world of Nintendo so
this is actually a bit of a catch-22
because they are really awful to
youtubers so I don't know how many
Nintendo games i'll be playing on my
youtube channel i will at least be
buying a couple of these games the first
being the new fire in one game which was
like shut up and take my money situation
next to Final Fantasy Fire Emblem is one
of my favorite franchises I just I've
always so disappointed that it's been
locked into Nintendo for so long there's
also a different game shin megami versus
Fire Emblem which looks even more
ridiculous in the best possible way
seriously this is like an anime hot mess
if you're big anime fan this is gonna be
your game really the interesting one
with Star Fox zero I haven't played a
starfox game in a long time so this
might be the one that gets me back in it
just had some really interesting
gameplay mechanics so we'll see I mean I
even like the n64 version that was the
last version that I played that's how
long it's been
living in to Ubisoft so they're actually
couple pretty good games Southpark the
fracture butthole I really love what
they did with stick of truth south park
itself just the way they animate the TV
show is perfect for video games it's
already kind of a video game all right
put the stick of truth in the toilet
that is not funny this is a holy reading
moving into Bioware territory starting
with Mass Effect Andromeda they said
that this won't involve Commander
Shepard from the main series and will be
in a completely different place which
I'm totally fine with so moving in a
Microsoft territory of course halo 5
auto by no need for an explanation there
same for fallout for the really
impressive thing about that is is that
they dropped the mobile game immediately
that's like the most perfect
presentation ever where it's like look
at this acid trip of a game that's going
to melt your brain oh wait we have a
mobile game that you can download right
now but this de has doom that was one of
those games that made my dad buy me my
own computer because I hog to our family
computer so much playing it right off
the bat I know a lot of you're asking
which of these I'm going to be streaming
on my game channel for those either
don't know yes I do have like a bonus
game channel it's just called Charlie's
streams there's a link in the
description also definitely fall out for
halo 5 and then the square games like
Final Fantasy near or two just depending
on what Square Enix allows to be
streamed most of the big game publishers
are really nice about gameplay videos
but some of the games are just off
limits like Nintendo is a really good
example that so that's why I probably
going to be doing a lot of Nintendo
videos what I'm hoping is is that by the
time most of these games come out later
this year I will have someone helping me
so i'll have more time to do game so
i'll at least do like one game video per
day on my game channel youtube has this
new video game website that nobody
really understands that well so once i
figure out what's going on with that
i'll post an update just in general
though expect more gameplay videos later
this year Arkham Knight is coming up so
I'll probably do a little bit of that
right away but this is mostly just
intended to be like a shout-out for the
games that I got really excited for it
III but if there are any games that you
guys really want me to play just let me
know in the comments like let me know
what are the games that you saw III that
you're most excited about I don't have
an ETA right now on gameplay videos so
just follow me on Twitter and Facebook
for updates there are links for that in
the description and in a link to my
bonus channel but why you got
wait for all that stuff you can click
here for my Game of Thrones finale Q&A
just to learn about what's going on with
season six and you can click here for my
season six predictions if you haven't
seen them yet thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five now
shut up and take my money